il faudrait peut-être tiré moi je vais
passer par mon opinion personnelle mais
on l'entend cette petite musique il ya
la presse qui fleurait christine aussi
est ce que il faut pas tirer les
conséquences que les mineurs
d'aujourd'hui ne sont pas ceux d'hier
ses yeux et qu'il faut maintenant
recourir peut-être à de la prison pour
des gens plus jeunes alors il ya des tas
d'arguments contre puisque la prison
c'est l'école du vice ils vont apprendre
d'autres mais quand on voit le sais pas
c'est peut même pas aller chercher un
massacre en règle du jeune jury moi vous
avez beau me dire qu'ils ont 15 ans
contrairement à une idée reçue d'un
mineur ne bénéficie pas d'une impunité
oui c'est tout à fait modérées s'ils
disent on peut pas aller en prison 6 à
13 ans et encore une autre règle etc
mais ce qu'il faut pas se poser la
question
il veut répondre ça peut mettre la
prison ça marche pas à la prison il
rentre il rencontre de mauvaise augure
et donc ils deviennent encore plus voyou
que bien des cas touchent le répète à
l'envi ronnement d'accord dans des
centres éducatifs s'ils sont jeunes très
dur on se lève à 6h du matin et on va
faire une heure deux heures de footing
version on s'en occupe
comme un art mais c'est ce qui se
comporte mal encore une fois jusqu'à 18
ans en fonction de six ont pris deux ou
trois ans de prison
service militaire obligatoire on peut
rajouter les travaux d'intérêts généraux
bernard juste oui parce que c'est
carrément pour un service militaire
pourquoi pas ou les centres spécialisés
et ses grandeurs avec des sensibilités
et c'est pourquoi pas accueillir
quelques d'ailleurs est ce un problème
avec ce qu'il faut comme un cadeau dans
le sol la seule problématique c'est
qu'il faut des moyens humains
considérables
un pas que du fait que les moyens la
polémique at il fermé ça coûte 700 euros
par jour par jeune il y en a 12 passes
entre ralenti mais il fait la
multiplication ce que ça coûte exacte et
ça marche moyennement il faut des choses
beaucoup plus dur mais après on se plie
à la problématique politique où on va
avoir évidemment des bien pensants qui
vont dire dolto au regard d'autres non
dolto la prison se faire aussi sans
doute
je réitère ma position puisque le sujet
traite de la délinquance des mineurs est
de la responsabilité des parents qui est
corrélé ou pas moi je maintiens ma
position en deçà de 15 ans donc il faut
être sur la responsabilisation parentale
au delà de 15 ans je pense qu'il faut
trouver une solution pour mettre le
gamin dans le droit chemin
la prison elle est criminogène la prison
c'est une fabrique un délinquant que tu
sors de la prison ne s'est pas vu un
caïd
surtout si tu as fait quelques mois
tient encore plus fort quand on sait
juste rentré de qu'il faut qu'on en tire
les enseignements en prison il ya 23 %
de personnes et qui relève de la
psychiatrie en prison soit des
délinquants chevronnés en prison tu as
un trafic à l'intérieur qui est pire
qu'à l'extérieur note il faut il faut
arrêter d'imaginer que la prison dans le
corrige de quai et ll réinsère c'est pas
vrai on aimerait mais c'est pas vrai
c'est une privation de liberté qui
protège un temps donné ça ne sauve pas
le veni vidi ça aide
ensuite mon je pense que quand on a 15
ans on n'est pas foutu
quand on a 15 ans on a besoin d'un cadre
et quand on n'a pas ce cadre ou parce
qu'on est sorti de ce cadre il faut
rappeler à ces jeunes effectivement
qu'il y en a un de câbles il faut pas le
faire avec une forme de laxisme ou de
légèreté et je pensais que le moment je
serais pour ans autour d'une forme de de
service national type un peu maison de
redressement donc mais pour doter le
gamin aussi je dirais 2 2
j'allais dire d'un cap et d'un bep de
quelque chose qui se sentent utiles qui
trouve sa place dans la société en lui
rappelant qu'à des règles le matin tu te
lèves
mais je suis désolé tu syrte et pompeux
tu fais ton ligne de combattants armés
va t'apprendre aussi les règles civiques
de bateaux rappelé qu'à la république
le poème est de combattre mais si c'est
dans la mention pas
la réalité la réalité c'est que je pense
qu'on a des fondamentaux qui mérite
d'être âpre des gamins de kent de ces
hommes qui ne sont pas foutus qui ont
commis une faute mais rendez vous compte
aujourd'hui la situation dans laquelle
nous sommes
oh mais 19 mois avant de statuer sur une
sanction potentielle des policiers
chargés d'assurer sur un gamin saison
non non non non mais t'es pas content et
il sait pas mais c'est parti au sénat
mais faisant ça a changé brusquement de
le voter
c'est pas effectif oui bien fait nous
parlons la justice entre un jeune qui
commet un acte de délinquance et la
sanction qui vient d'alain 19 ans il
s'en passer des choses mais je suis mal
magané compatissant dire moi aussi
j'aimerais que en suivant ces années le
service national qui n'existe plus hélas
j'aimerais qu'il soit pas considérée
comme une poubelle dans laquelle on
mettrait les délinquants on inventerait
autisme punitive bien sûr pour maîtriser
non mais on tourne autour de l'option
militaire mais dans la moyenne
d'autant que ça j'ai recherché pour
meurtre pour avoir fait mon service
militaire je peux vous dire une chose
c'est qu'effectivement on a pu j'étais
officier redresser un certain nombre de
gens qui étaient vraiment mal barré dans
la vie ce qu'ils ont et origination on
leur a appris à lire on leur a pris
écriront leur a appris à conduire à
passer leur permis à devenir éducateur
au même mais il faut quand même voir ce
que c'était que service militaire la
machine a plus inégalitaires du monde
fait de uniquement de pistonner c'est à
dire que là encore les gens des beaux
quartiers les fils à papa arriver à
passer entre les gouttes en faisant leur
service militaire au sirpa dans le 7e
arrondissement dans une entreprise à lui
classé son lit
j'ai pas les favoriser en bénéficier oui
malheureusement seuls défavorisés se
faisait leur service militaire lui